hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve search a 2d matrix and i
really like this problem because it's
not one of those problems that you need
a fancy trick for you can actually solve
this problem just by using logic so we
are tasked with creating an efficient
algorithm for searching for a single
value in an m by n matrix the matrix has
two properties in every single row the
integers are sorted from left to right
and the first integer of each row for
example this 10 is always going to be
greater than the last integer of the
previous row so greater than this one so
in other words we know that each row is
sorted and then the next row is going to
be greater than that so technically each
value in total throughout the entire
matrix is going to be in sorted order so
that's pretty good in this example we
were given a target 3 so if we search
for the target we will find it right
here so then we can return true that it
does exist if it does not exist then we
simply return false so how can we solve
this problem the key word here is create
an efficient algorithm what would be the
brute force of course we could do an
algorithm o of m by n basically by
searching every single value in the
input array right that's a pretty easy
algorithm to do on a two-dimensional
matrix but can we do better of course we
can because they gave us a couple
properties that this matrix has some
sorting already applied to it assume
that we just had a single row like
forget that we had a matrix if we just
had a single row like this one and we
know it's in sorted order do you know an
algorithm that can search for a target
value in a sorted array
i know of one called binary search right
and how efficient is binary search well
let's say
the size of this array is n we could do
a binary search in log n time right but
of course we know that we actually have
m
different rows right so let's say we ran
a binary search on every single row
until we found the input target value
right what would the time complexity be
well log n multiplied by m is going to
give us a solution like that so that's
using the first property knowing that
each rows integers are sorted but and
this is a pretty good solution but can
we do even better than this i'll give
you a hint we're definitely gonna have
to use this second property that they
told us each row itself is actually in
sorted order as in we know that the
values in this row are going to be
smaller than all of the values in this
row and all the values in this row are
going to be smaller than all the values
in this row so can we use that property
to instead of searching through every
one of these m rows maybe we can
actually do a binary search just to
figure out which one of these rows to
search in the first place because for
example if we're looking for a target
value 3 let's take a look at this row
this row could have any values between
10 which is the lower bound and between
20. so obviously the target value 3 is
not going to fall within that range
between 10 and 20 right so then the
question is okay if the if the target
value is definitely not in this row we
can cross this row out but then which
direction are we going to go are we
going to look at the row above it or are
we going to look at the row below it of
course we would want to look at the one
above right because above the top row is
going to have smaller values than the
bottom row right so when we cross this
row out we can also say that you know
let's cross this row out too because of
course this row is going to have greater
values that's how the binary search is
going to work to even figure out which
one of these m rows we're going to need
to search right so we can reduce instead
of m we can do a log m by running binary
search after we've ran that log m search
then we know okay this is the row that
we have to do our second binary search
on so after we're done with that we're
going to do another binary search so
let's plus here log
n
right log n
for binary searching the row itself so
that's a better time complexity than we
had previously right log m plus log n
that's pretty dang good so once we get
to this row we're going to say okay 3 is
what we're looking for does that fall in
the range between 1 and between 7 of
course it does so either our target
value exists in this row or it doesn't
exist at all so let's run binary search
here so of course we're gonna have two
pointers left pointer and right pointer
then we're gonna check the middle value
in this case i think the middle value is
gonna end up being this one because zero
plus three is gonna become index one but
let's just say it became this one just
to kind of show you what it's going to
look like let's say our middle value is
here we're going to check okay 5 is that
3 nope 3 is less than 5. so what we can
do in our binary search is cross out
these values cross out our pointers now
our right pointer is going to be over
here and let's say we ran binary search
again we compute the mid to be over here
we check is this 3 nope 3 is greater
than this so we cross this out and we
shift our left pointer over here left
and right are both here middle is going
to be here as well we're gonna see okay
either this has to be three or nothing
or three just doesn't exist of course
this is three so we found it we can
return
true and that's the entire solution so
it's just a double binary search and we
can implement that pretty easily once
you kind of know how to do binary search
and if you don't i'm going to show you
how to do it right now so now let's get
into the code so the first thing i like
to do is actually get the dimensions of
the matrix so let's get the rows and the
number of columns in this matrix we can
do that pretty easily because we know
for sure that the matrix is always going
to be non-empty and now we're going to
do the first binary search we're going
to look for the row that we need to find
so i'm going to have two pointers one
for the top row and one for the bottom
row top row is zero the bottom row is
going to be the number of rows minus one
so now we're just going to continue to
do the binary search until we can either
find the target row or we we figure out
that the target row does not even exist
in the binary search so one case is that
the target value is even greater than
the largest value in this row so let's
go to that row okay first before i do
that let me actually compute the row so
we want the middle row in this case
we'll take the top and bottom and divide
it by two
that's kind of how binary search usually
goes right so and then we have that row
so in our matrix we're going to look at
that row and we're going to look at the
right most value in python you can do
that with negative 1 but we could also
just do number of rows minus or the
number of columns minus 1 but in python
it's a little bit easier so we're going
to check is this target value greater
than the largest value in this row if
that's the case what are we going to do
well then we need to look at rows with
even larger values so what we're going
to say is our bottom row is going to end
up being the the current row plus one
because now we want to look at rows that
are uh larger than this row else if the
exact opposite happens so let me copy
and paste this if the target value was
even less than the leftmost value in the
array aka the target value was smaller
than the smallest value in this row and
that's in that case we need to look at
rows with smaller values so we're going
to shift our top pointer actually i
think i just did it backwards so when we
look for larger values we actually want
to take our top pointer and then shift
it down because when you go down in the
matrix is when you actually get larger
values and when we if we want to look
for smaller values we're going to take
our bottom pointer and then shift it up
in that case we would want to set it to
be row minus one so that's the case if
the target value was either too big or
too small if neither of those evaluates
to true that means that the target value
is actually
actually does fall within this current
row in that case we just want to break
out of this while loop and then we can
do the second portion of the binary
search now it's possible that if we uh
did not break out maybe we just created
an invalid condition where we figured
out that the top and bottom
pointers are invalid right then our
while loop would stop and what that
would tell us is that we crossed out
every single row in the matrix and none
of the rows contained the target value
in that case we have to return false
immediately so basically if not top is
less than or equal to bottom that means
that none of the rows contain the target
value and then we can just immediately
return false if that's not the case then
we're going to move on to the second
binary search portion and we're going to
run binary search on the current row
that we found from the top and bottom
pointer so let me just copy and paste
that this is the row that we're going to
run binary search on and we're going to
have a couple pointers left and right
which is going to be 0 and
columns minus 1 because that's going to
be the right most position in the row
and we're going to do the pretty much
the exact same thing that we just wrote
above a second binary search while left
is less than or equal to right let's
compute the middle point we can do that
by taking left plus right divided by 2
and now we'll do the same thing so if we
find that the target value is greater
than the value in this target row at
position middle that means we have to
search towards the right of the row we
have to search towards the right of this
middle point in which case we'll say our
left pointer is going to be m
plus 1. we're going to search towards
the right else if the exact opposite was
true then we want to search towards the
right so we can shift our right pointer
to be mid minus one
and else the last case is if we actually
did find the target value in that case
of course we can return true now if this
loop exited but we never returned to
true then outside of the loop then we
have to return false meaning that we
never found the target value okay i just
forgot that when we're copy and pasting
i forgot to change this condition so the
first one of course is if target is
greater the second else if is target if
target is smaller then we want to shift
the opposite pointer and that is the
entire code so you can see that it's
pretty efficient so i hope that this was
helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching